[Musica]
[Applauso]
come stai vestito il 63 vitale non mai
mario non capisco si può sapere perché
io non è che titolo di molti temi
trasformare anche tu dobbiamo nascondere
tutte le monete e sconfiggere il dato
nel castello sconfiggere nessun drago ma
sì certo mi aiuterà in questo anzi
iniziamo subito la trasformazione dove
resta sì sì sì
[Musica]
in cosa mi ha trasformato il feature
pikes peak la principessa di supermario
dimmi come faccio a tornare come prima
ma perché mi ritornare come prima perché
io voglio essere me stessa non la
principessa bbb
si chiama ti suite e adesso andiamo a
raccogliere tutte le volete ancora con
queste monete lo voglio raccogliere le
monete voglio tornare come prima
allora guarda ti porta a farti vedere
allo specchio così vedi quanto sei bella
va bene andiamo a vederci respiriamo ma
sono anche bionda e questo vestito
benefit è niente male quindi che i
viaggi già no preferisco torneremo meno
prima se vuoi tornare numeri prima
dovrei allora trovare tutti gli
ingredienti slime è diciamo che me la
cavo abbastanza bene a trovare gli
ingredienti stima e quindi potrei anche
riuscirci ma glielo impedirò tirate
motivo gli arti cattivi addosso ma
perché rendono più difficile posso
tenere
almeno dopo no assolutamente semplici
questa feature potere vestito e la
corona neanche mi guardi e nessuno potrà
impedire male tornerò come prima e
dovrei trovarmi un'altra principessa
peach per raccogliere le tue monete o
quello che questo vedremo
andiamo ragazzi riusciremo a trovare
tutt'altra parte ma chi farà ma mi
stanno correndo con quello strano fungo
chiudiamolo ok l'abbiamo chiuso fuori
perché non riesca ad aprire la porta
comunque dobbiamo trovare tutti gli
ingredienti slime per tornare come prima
devo dire che questi capelli folti
capelli biondi non mi dispiacciono voi
cosa ne pensate stupidi bionda 8 meglio
con i capelli castani va bene comunque
dobbiamo sbrigarci adesso come sempre
iniziamo a guardare qua nello studio in
genere si nascondono sempre molte cose
cos'è quella scatola strana guardate non
c'era prima questa scatolina qua sopra
un punto di domanda soffrano forse una
trappola è una trappola messa da mario
per trovare tutte le sue monetine come
dice lui di quanti non riesco ad aprile
un bel niente
sistri uscita c'è la ciotola e poi la
spatola rosa che semina il mio partito
dove è viva finora sono stata molto
fortunata devo dire ok in via libera
andiamo di qua guardate un po la
soluzione per me è proprio ancora devo
dirti questa challenger sta andando
abbastanza bene nonostante fosse un
posto ma che cos'è questo mario mi ha
tirato uno di quei funghetti malefici
ora ho solo una vita o ancora da trovare
il bicarbonato
una colla e la soluzione per me io per
fortuna anche se mi ha preso sono
riuscita a prenderla
però abbiamo solo una possibilità sarà
molto difficile
proviamo a controllare fuori in giardino
ok ragazzi siamo fuori in giardino
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa qua anche
voi tempi gli occhi impegno perde e
ditemi se vedete qualcosa e mario
guardate è entrato nello studio sono
scappata giusto in tempo
ma cercando di tirarmi fungo ma non ci
riesce perché c'è il vetro ma mario è un
po e un po tonto non puoi vermi niente
ciao ciao mario ciao ciao
vediamo un po a volte ci sono anche cose
nascoste qua nelle palme un po strano
questo fungo enorme coloratissimo forse
un fungo velenoso che dite provò a
prenderlo a degli oggetti che carino
prendiamolo eccolo qua il super carino
ma non so se un fungo velenoso
forse è meglio se esistono attenta lo
tocco strano con i guanti
penso che il fungo mi abbia dato una
vita in più perché questo non è uno di
quei funghi malefici di mario ma è un
fungo è buono grazie funghetto ma ora
continuiamo la ricerca ma era proprio
quale il bicarbonato però proprio qui
davanti a me non voglio raccorda grazie
funghetto mi hai portato un sacco di
fortuna ora mi tocca tornare dentro da
mario ci vediamo dopo andiamo
mi dispiace per te mario ma anche se mi
hai colpito con il tuo fungo malefico io
ho avuto una vita in più grazie al
funghetto buono o no che sembra che stia
seguendo chiudiamoci quali studio ai
ragazzi abbiamo il bicarbonato
la soluzione per lady la ciotola e la
spatola
manca solo una cosa la colla devo stare
molto attenta però perché ho nuovamente
soltanto una vita anche se avevo preso
un altra vita grazie al funghetto poi
mario mi ha presa con il suo funghetto e
quindi l'ho persa nuovamente e quindi ho
solo una vita mi è venuta in mente una
cosa proviamo a ricontrollare dentro al
cubo
magari c'è qualcosa che ti amo
no non c'è niente dentro apriamolo lo
stesso ecco come non detto
dentro non c'è niente aspetto momento
[Musica]
che cos'è questo foglietto che cos'è
secondo voi sembra il cappello di mario
disegnato un po male devo forse usarlo
per sbloccare qualcosa
pensiamoci bene cosa vorrà dire il
cappello di mario forse vuol dire che
nel cappello di mario si nasconde
qualcosa
la colonna potrebbe essere nel cappello
di mario cioè nella sua testa quindi
dovrò trovare il modo di togliersi il
cappello vedere se c'è la colla sempre
sperando che questo sia un indizio buono
un vero indizio umbero indizio giusto
però dobbiamo provare perché altrimenti
non sappiamo dove cercare mario eccolo
arrivato subito
vieni qui devo dirti una cosa minima
ritornati a freddo momento non tirare
quel fungo perché ho solo una vita
[Musica]
aspetta devo darti una notizia
ok con la notizia ho cambiato idea
ho deciso che verrò con te e catture no
com'era prenderemo tutte le monete
e andremo a sconfiggere il drago nel
castello contento però ho solo una
condizione
dobbiamo scambiarsi il cappello è
possibile ma non si svolta sostitutiva
al cappello ma aspetta to prenderesti la
mia corona e il tuo cappello fanno uno
scambio corona è bello capello corona
problemi
ok allora ho un'altra condizione di un
funghetto no come fai serviti re un
funghetto perdo tutte le vite poi non
potrò venire con te a prendere tutte le
monete allora l'altra condizione è che
prima di partire per questa avventura tu
dovrai fare un pisolino si arriva ad ora
fuori pisolini bene o male devi dormire
qua però vorrei darmi è però devi
dormire molto e riposarti molte
altrimenti non potremo partire per
l'avventura dormire riposarti io starò
qui
a guardarti berlino berlino non
svegliate fini qua no perché non lo devi
dormire ok tu dormi mi raccomando da
rino mi riguardi di qui vieni qua bravo
lasciato no o forse vuole avvisarlo
quindi marino da lavori di mario berrino
iniqua
andiamo subito ci siamo se mi segue
anche se ho paura che rimarrà con mario
merlino come faccio adesso con berlino
mariano si addormenterà mai
ok berlino uscito mario si sta
tormentando
io comprenderà corso e si pensi mi
[Musica]
per fortuna sta ancora dormendo berlino
in super silenzio sta dormendo mentre la
colla nella ciotola
[Musica]
ho sottoscritto di sbrigarsi ecco fatto
non capisco perché non sono tornata come
prima mario aveva detto che se trovavo
tutti gli ingredienti stai mi facevo lo
slime sarei tornata come prima ma sono
ancora forse devo svegliare mario e devo
farli vederlo
mario sveglia degli a mario devo dirti
una cosa importante mario mario sveglia
mario può fargli il solletico sotto i
mari mario devo dirti una cosa
importantissima
tieni avvicinati pure chi fa le guarda
il forum si quindi mi dispiace ma io
devo tornare me stessa e va bene è viva
hai vinto
allora mi devi dare lo slime e mi devi
ridare il gioco grazie mi avesse gioco
tieni allora sì pronta altissima
ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi lui o forse ragione
stessa tornata vita ma mai arrivare a
ciò cosa farai andrò a raccogliere tutte
le volte che candiderà sai dove ti
barbie e mario bel ragazzo abbiamo visto
neanche questo challenge se volete
rivedere mario lasciate un bel mi piace
su questo video a 30 mila mi piace ci
sarà un altro video con supermario e
chissà se io mi trasformerò ancora in
principessa peach o nel drago o in
qualcos'altro
quindi mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi
piace ora vi lascio da quattro caselline
scudi care per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione
ciao
[Musica]